the phone on my right bulb is moved towards the center.
Uh-huh.
And I'm wondering how to remedy that situation.
Sure. So you have the two rubber caps on either end.
This happens very often.
Okay.
So if you just pull the rubber end off where the foam is starting to fall in,
grab a needle nose pliers,
you should be able to grasp the end of that foam from the needle nose pliers
and pull that towards the edge.
Once it reaches the edge, what I've told people is if they wanted to take a single dab of
a gorilla glue or, you know, super glue and just do one little dot
at the very end of that tube on the inside and then press the foam up into that.
It should dry fairly quick and it will just hold that little spot in place.
So it's less likely to break away and slip down towards the center.
Okay. Great.